.
PETE MUNTEAN, CNN, REAGAN
NATIONAL AIRPORT.
>> MEANWHILE, GREECE IS QUICKLY
WORKING TO VACCINATE AS MANY
PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE FOR THE
TOURISM GETS INTO FULL SWING.
THE GOAL IS TO HAVE COVID FREE
ISLANDS, IN AN EFFORT TO MAKE
TRAVELERS FEEL MORE CONFIDENT
AND BOOKING THOSE TRIPS.
HERE IS CNN'S SAM KILEY.
>> NOT EXACTLY THE MODERN
TEMPLE TO APHRODITE, THAT IT
HAS A REPUTATION FOR.
THE PARTY ISLAND, BARELY WAKING
UP, 2 WEEKS AFTER THE OFFICIAL
TOURIST SEASON WAS DECLARED.
OPEN.
MUSEUMS ARE STILL LOCKED UP,
MANY SHOPS SHUTTERED.
OTHERS ARE GETTING A MAKE OVER,
WELL PLANS TO CREATE MORE THAN
80 COVID FREE ISLANDS GET
UNDERWAY.
IT IS THE CENTERPIECE OF
OPERATION BLUE FREEDOM.
THE GREAT PLAN FOR ECONOMIC
RECOVERY, DRIVEN BY TOURISM.
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC, A 5TH OF
THE POPULATION WAS EMPLOYED IN
THE INDUSTRY, AND GENERATED 18%
OF GDP.
WITH U.S. VISITORS BEING
INCREASES BIGGEST SPENDERS,
ATHENS IS BANKING ON A SUMMER
SURGE IN AMERICAN VISITORS, AND
U.S. AIRLINES ARE INCREASING
FLIGHTS FROM WHEN YOU'RE HERE
AND I HAVE THEM FOR PITTSBURGH,
MUNICH, WASHINGTON D.C.?
>> THE KEY IS AN AGGRESSIVE
EXHIBITION CAMPAIGN TO JAB
EVERY ISLAND RESIDENT BY THE,
END OF JUNE, WHO CAN SO AND SEE
IF THEY SURVIVED INFECTION, OR
NOT HAVE A NEGATIVE PCR TEST.
>> IT'S A COVID FREE ISLAND,
AND WE AWAIT ALL TOURISTS TO
ARRIVE HERE, TO ENJOY THE
BEACHES, TO ENJOY THE LIFE.
>> GETTING THAT DONE MAY REST
ON ENDING NATIONWIDE
REGULATIONS, THAT BAND MUSIC,
AND CROWDS.
IT IS A HEART DOCTOR, WHO ALSO
OWNS SEVERAL NIGHTCLUBS, AND
HOTELS.
HIS CLIENTS COHEN WITH 2
QUESTIONS, ESPECIALLY FROM
AMERICA.
>> FIRST, WE ASK YOU HOW WE ARE
ALL VACCINATED, AND SECONDLY,
IF THEY CAN PARTAKE IN THE
ISLAND LIKE THEY USED TO.
>> THAT IS THE MAGIC RECIPE.
>> 18% OF GREEKS, FULLY
VACCINATED.
NEW COVID CASES ARE FALLING,
AND DEATHS ARE ABOUT 40 PER DAY.
FOR NOW, THE CLUBS ARE EMPTY.
ONLY COCKTAIL SHAKER, IS
GENERATING ANY RHYTHM.
POTION FROM SEARCY, TO SOFTEN
THE BLUES.
>> TOURISTS ARE TRICKLING BACK,
AND THEY DO THEIR BEST TO ENJOY
A BEACH, WITHOUT DECIMALS OF
DANCE MUSIC.
BUT, WITH MORE THAN HALF OF THE
RESIDENTS POPULATION PRESENT,
ALL EYES HIS EYES TURNED LITTLE
ATHENS TO UNLEASH TIE ON ISIS,
AND LET THE FUN BEGIN IN JULY.
>> IS NOT NECESSARILY THAT THE
TOURISTS NEED TO FEEL MUCH
SAFER TO COME, TO PARTY, AND
FEEL SAFE.
FOR EXAMPLE, PEOPLE LAST YEAR
WERE READY TO PARTY.
IT WAS HARD FOR US TO ENFORCE
THE RULES ON THEM.
BUT, I THINK WE ARE ALL TRAINED
NOW, US CLIENTELE, AND EVERYONE,
SO I THINK THAT THIS WILL BE A
BIT THIS SUMMER.
>> THAT IS IF HADESTOWN WAS
YOUR THING FOR THE MORE MATURE
TRAVELER, THAT CAN ONLY BE A
RELIEF